i got a chance to witness
neurolink i don't know if you're
familiar with that company's brain
yeah brain computer interfaces and then
they have i got a chance to see
it in person just a bunch of pigs who
had neurolink chips implanted
and taken out those pigs are so happy
with life
i don't know i've never seen a happier
animal
i mean because they get to eat you
because you were mentioning sort of
diets and stuff
they basic pigs seem to love a lot of
stuff
if they're easy they're easily made to
be happy i don't know if
you can comment on your thoughts of um
of you know exploring the capacity
of the pig mind through some of this
testing when you're a link
whether that's exciting to you whether
maybe on the humane side it's a little
bit concerning
um if there's something to be said
sort of like um yeah on the
i don't know if it's even the ethical
side but just because of your connection
to meat
and to nature and understanding these
living beings
well pigs are incredibly intelligent so
i'm not surprised that they're a subject
matter for neural link
um they're smarter than dogs and they're
empathetic and emotional
um and they're we'll go look at our pigs
afterwards and
see but they're they're they're kind of
like joyful and exuberant when they're
in good health
and um so that that makes sense
i i'm interested in open i feel
um that the
kind of bleeding edge agriculture
movement that i'm
you know on the edge of in some ways
we're a larger operator but we as a
movement have to
we have to get into the game we have to
move forward in a way that allows us to
scale
if we want to be viable so i think there
has to be openness to how that can
happen
yeah and i also think there needs to be
more thoughtful
and noisy data about how regenerative
ranching can sequester carbon i mean
thousands of american ranchers are
selling carbon credits right now
the data is that valid and they're not
selling carbon credits from like
grassland that just got a fence around
it they're selling carbon credits for
verified data from
animals assisting in carbon
sequestration right so there's got to be
a way to to get the tech community
involved
in ways to help regenerative agriculture
scale in different creative ways
and actually yeah that'd be interesting
if like neurolink somehow has
i mean especially because you know musk
is involved in kimball mosques and
like has his whole effort and
appreciation of
regenerative agriculture that i wonder
if neurolink has a role to play
like exploring the the neurobiology of
the animal
if that somehow will create innovations
that uh
lead to improved
uh scaling of regenerative agriculture
it'd be interesting but
you're saying you should be open to all
those possibilities i don't think i
don't know the landscape to know
what yeah but my sense is that it's very
hard
it's very hard and our farming operation
to scale has been
incredibly complex and challenging we
now work with partner firms
i see their operations they're
incredibly complex you know it just
seems like there's got to be a way to
make some of these things
simpler and easier to share information
yeah um
i don't know what that answer the answer
is you know what would be cool
is if we can understand deeper ways to
measure
the happiness of an animal because then
we can optimize
like a certified humane could be
literally an optimization problem just
make sure
as opposed to kind of uh using our
projecting our own human values
actually measuring what the what the
animals have to be doing that could be
so understanding the pig brain
might help us understand pig happiness
and
like reframe what it means for a happy
animal and then maybe it's a lot easier
to make a happy animal
to make the animal happy than we think
you